police nationale municipale pompiers et
le pôle pilote de sécurité locale
d'Élancourt ses services bientôt
travailleront de concerts pour
intervenir au plus vite sur le terrain
le but gagner du temps pour sauver
encore plus de vie le PPSL est un centre
pour tester les nouvelles technologies
dans le domaine de la sécurité pour les
forces de secours les forces de police
qui ont besoin d'intervenir très
rapidement d'échanger de l'information
et de comprendre ce qui se passe sur une
situation on offre les technologies qui
permettent d'y répondre
analyse de cartographies études des
zones à risque utilisation des réseaux
sociaux en cas de crise grâce à ces
nouvelles technologies la qualité la
rapidité et la précision de
l'information s'accroît pour un meilleur
rendu sur le terrain et entre les
services
le PPSL entre guillemets est à quelques
mètres du commissariat c'est bien sûr
pour qu'il synergie d'expérimentation et
bien sûr aider nos
équipes de police à avoir le meilleur
matériel le plus performant une
performance qui passe par le partenariat
avec plus de 50 grandes et petites
entreprises qui offrent leur technologie
et leur savoir au service de la sécurité
et des forces de secours